[ Applause ]
>> Karyn Temple: Good morning.
Welcome to our 20th
copyright matters event.
I am Karen Temple,
Acting Director
of the United States
Copyright Office.
Today we are excited
to be celebrating the
lifecycle of copyright.
What do I mean by the
lifecycle of copyright?
Well generally, our friends at
Webster define the lifecycle
as "the series of stages
through which something,
such as an individual, culture
or manufactured product
passes during its lifetime."
While copyright, of course,
is not a living organism,
it too has a lifecycle
and passes
through many stages over time.
Starting from the
very beginning,
when it's not even a copyright
yet, but simply an idea
or thought that serves as
that seed for a later piece
of artwork, that then grows into
a fully formed copyrighted work,
such as a book, song,
photograph or painting.
Over the course of its lifecycle
that copyrighted work may
spread far and wide on its own
as it adapts and
generates other works.
And finally, at the end of
its copyright lifecycle,
when the full copyright term of
protection has been achieved,
the copyright work returns
figuratively to the earth,
as it enters the public
domain and is free to use
and reuse by everyone.
I still find it amazing
and inspiring
that the founding
fathers were able
to appreciate the extraordinary
importance of copyright
and the copyright lifecycle
by enshrining it article one
of our constitution insuring
both strong copyright
protection, but also recognizing
the value of limited terms
and the public domain.
The full value and beauty
of our copyright system can
unfortunately sometimes be
forgotten and seen as
some sort of barrier
to creation and innovation.
When, in fact, it
is far from that.
As the Supreme Court
has recognized,
copyright is the engine
of free expression.
And the lifecycle of copyright
including its exceptions,
limited term and the
public domain is all part
of that critically
important framework created
on our constitution.
So today, we have the distinct
pleasure to celebrate part
of that lifecycle in a way
that we have not been
able to do for some time.
On January 1 of this year,
hundreds of works that had been
under copyright protection
entered into the public domain.
These were works that
had been created in 1923.
Many have been widely
recognizable
for almost 100 years, songs
such as the Charleston,
as you just heard and
yes we have No Bananas.
Films just as Harold
Lloyd's Safety Last.
Buster Keaton's, Our Hospitality
and Charlie Chaplan's
The Pilgrim.
Books, stories and essays by
the likes of PG - GK Chesterton,
Anton Chekov, Agatha
Christie, Aldous Huxley,
F. Scott Fitzgerald,
Rudyard Kipling,
Sinclair Lewis and
P.G. Woodhouse.
These works would have entered
the public domain in 1999,
but then following the
lead of the European Union
and to protect American
authors from inequity overseas,
Congress extended
copyright protection
in the United States
by 20 years.
And so this year is the
first time in two decades
that a large batch of older
works has simultaneously fallen
into the public domain
at one time.
It is important to recognize
that when a work enters the
public domain of course,
it does not represent the death
of copyright; rather it is part
of copyright's lifecycle.
The next stage of life
for that creative work.
The public domain is an
inherent and integral part
of the copyright system.
So, when people say that
they value copyright law,
the public domain is a
crucial component of that.
In fact, throughout our history
artistic hits have been often
adaptations of classics that
were in the public domain
or new creations called
from public domain sources.
Hollywood films, Kiss Me Kate
and more recently 10 Things I
Hate About You are adaptations
of Shakespeare's
Taming of the Shrew.
The 2009 novel and movie
Pride and Prejudice
and Zombie's is an adaptation
of Jane Austen's classic novel
and Beyonce's Ave Maria is
an adaptation of Schubert's.
In fact, many popular
animated movies
and theater productions
are modern
and commercially
successful takes
on classic public
domain fairy tales.
Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs, Cinderella,
Sleeping Beauty,
Beauty and the Beast.
This lifecycle of copyright is
crucial to the overall system.
It provides authors the
inspiration and raw material
to create something new.
And that is why it is valued
by both authors and users,
because often when it comes
to the public domain
authors are users
and users are authors
of copyrighted works.
And that's why today we
are celebrating it here
at the United States
Copyright Office.
With that I would like to
invite up Whitney Levandusky,
an attorney with the Office of
Public Information and Education
at the Copyright Office.
Whitney will talk a bit more
about the public domains
importance and how it functions.
She'll also introduce our
esteemed speakers for today.
So with that, I will
turn it over to Whitney.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Whitney Levandusky:
Thank you.
As we heard from Acting
Register Karyn Temple,
we're here to celebrate the
public domain, the next stage
of life for a creative work.
The Constitution allowed
Congress to grant copyright,
but it also set forth
that the protection was
for a limited time.
This limited nature is important
to the creative life
of the United States.
Today, you will learn
about the many angles
of the public domain.
How does it work
for creative people?
How can it work for each of us?
And where can we find it?
We'll learn about how public
domain works provide an ongoing
and renewable legacy
of creativity.
We'll hear from a documentarian
and a musical historian
about how the public domain
assists and shapes their work.
We will also explore
this rich background
and highlight some works
and authors of those works
that are entering the
public domain this year.
So, the public domain,
it's not a place.
We can't find it on a map.
When we say public
domain, we mean simply
that the work is not
protected by copyright
and it's free for anyone to use.
The public domain is a
wellspring of knowledge
and creativity that allows
individuals at institutions
to supply new creativity
and thought.
Vampires -
Pride and Prejudice.
The works of Jules
Verne and H.G. Wells.
These are just a
few brief examples
about how we've used
the public domain
to inspire new creative works.
The public domain
gives us the ability
to stretch our imaginations,
to take common touchstones
to new places, and
re-evaluate long-standing works
in contemporary times.
While we are highlighting
today the end of copyright term
as one way of growing the
public domain, Karyn mentioned
that the public domain
is far more than works
who copyright term has ended.
There are a number of other
ways that work - that works are
in the public domain
from their inception.
All works, for example
created by federal employees
in the scope of their employment
are in the public domain.
A small sampling of works
created by employees
in the public trust
include the fruits
of the works progress
administration.
The first photograph of earth
by astronaut Bill
Anders, titled Earth Rise.
Photographs from field work
by government agencies.
Medical imageries -
Medical imagery, there we go.
And of course, studies
and reports produced
by the government including
the copyright office.
And oftentimes we
use the public domain
to extend beyond creative works.
We use public domain to
refer to the building blocks
of knowledge and creativity.
Things like facts, processes
and systems, basic shapes,
social dances, short
words and phrases.
All in all, the public domain
is the wealth of resources
that are available to everyone.
Now there may be no more
immediate example of inspiration
of public domain works than
those penned by Shakespeare.
The Folger Shakespeare Library,
which is just across the street
from us, it has the largest
collection of materials relating
to Shakespeare and his works,
which includes centuries
of adaptations on the stage,
in music, in art and for film.
We will be using
the long history
of Shakespearian
inspiration as the focal point
to examine the important role
of public domain
works and adaptation.
Our first presenter
is Douglas Lanier.
He is the Professor of English
at University of New Hampshire,
and a long term research fellow
at the Folger Shakespeare
Library.
He did is graduate work at Duke
University, and he specialized
in medieval and early
modern drama.
He has taught at Duke, UCLA,
Alleghany College, Gonville
and Caius College, Cambridge,
the University of Milan
and University de
Murcia in Spain.
His pioneering work in the
study of modern adaptations
of Shakespeare in mass media
will provide the foundation
for his insight into the
cultural recirculation
of public domain works,
the cultural after-life
and the elevation of works
through adaptations over time.
His book, Shakespeare and
Modern Popular Culture,
established the basic
parameters of one
of the five most
liveliest fields
of Shakespeare studies today.
He is currently at work
on two book projects.
First, a history of
screen adaptation
of an Othello worldwide,
and second a study
of reparative Shakespeare,
which are productions
of Shakespeare addressed
to the traumas
of socially marginalized groups.
So please welcome me - in
joining - in welcoming Douglas.
[ Applause ]
>> Douglas Lanier:
Hello, can you hear me?
Of the original public - oops.
There we go.
The original public
domain materials
in western culture are what
we've come to call the classics
of Greek and Latin antiquity.
They did not begin
their lives as classics.
These works were freely
available for creative use,
rhetoricians call imitation,
by all who can master
the written languages.
It was through their
recirculation and adapted form
that they attained the
status of a classic.
The word classic then specifies
not some monumental steady
state, but the result
of an ongoing dynamic,
always historically
contingent process.
An important condition of
which is the works availability
in the public realm.
And this process of
classicizing involves a paradox.
The cultural after-life
of a work depends upon its being
creatively altered, repurposed,
appropriated, made
into something other
than its former self.
A work is effectively dead
unless it has new readers
and audiences, new performers
and adapters who allow it
to speak to a new present.
I'm going to dodge for the
moment some very tricky
questions about politics
and ethics
in this process of
appropriation.
There's nothing to guarantee
that adaptations will be
faithful to their sources
and nothing to guarantee
that adaptations will serve
socially responsible purposes.
Here I want simply to
observe that a condition
for art having a
robust after-life is
that it is available
for creative adaptation.
Now in the Anglophone
literary tradition,
several artists have achieved
the status of classics;
Jane Austen, Charlotte Bronte
and Charles Dickens come
immediately to mind.
But none has had a history of
adaptation as long, as varied,
as global in scope
as Shakespeare.
He is the Coca Cola
of literature.
And through the - and
though the reasons
for his extraordinary
cultural after-life are many,
one key is that Shakespeare's
work has long been
in the public domain.
And therefore, an irresistible
object for adaptation.
Now it's possible to think
about Shakespearian
adaptation from several angles.
One has to do with medium.
Shakespeare's dramatic
writing needs to be converted
from its initial form as a
script into a living performance
for any of his works
to become a play.
Interestingly, Shakespeare's
early cultural after-life
involve his being presented
in the public realm
in two forms at once.
As a stage performance,
developing in a number
of directions over the
18th and 19th century.
And as a printed book, first
appearing as the first folio
in 1623 the printed collection
that redefined Shakespeare
as an object for readers
rather than theater audiences.
Now this two-track mode of
adaptation, stage and print,
the two predominant
literary modes
of the period may
have much to do
with Shakespeare's
status as a classic.
As new media emerged
in cultural importance,
so too did Shakespeare
become accommodated to them.
The 19th century for
example was particularly keen
to adapt Shakespeare to the
newly ascended form of opera
and instrumental music.
In the 20th century, here we go,
Shakespeare's writings have
been adapted to all modes
of new media, advertising
motion pictures, radio,
audio performance, television,
digital text, even social media.
In the central function
of Shakespearian
adaptation has been
to make new media formats seem
less intimidating and alien,
to demonstrate their utility or
lend them cultural authority.
This is particularly
true at moments
where a new medium might seem
to threaten the cultural
status quo; such was the case
with silent Shakespeare films
in the early 20th century
or radio Shakespeare in
the US in the mid-1930's.
In a process we call reciprocal
legitimation Shakespeare serves
to legitimize the new medium,
while at the same time
the new medium serves
to legitimize Shakespeare's
status as a classic
and reconfirm his place
in the public realm
for a new generation.
Now I should stress that this -
that each new media
manifestation
of Shakespeare always involves
reconceiving what Shakespeare
can be.
It's never just a
matter of reformatting.
Film Shakespeare
is very different
from stage Shakespeare,
print Shakespeare,
televisional Shakespeare,
radio Shakespeare.
Each of these media
highlight certain elements
of Shakespeare's art and
makes new perceptions
of his achievement possible.
We come to Shakespeare on film,
with different expectations
of realism than we do
with print Shakespeare
or stage Shakespeare.
The actors work and technique
is different in film Shakespeare
than it is in audio
or stage productions.
And how we experience our
Shakespeare in the theater
and home, on a large or
small screen, in live
or recorded format effects
how we understand the nature
and significance of
Shakespeare's art.
A new media can get
us to think anew
about Shakespeare's
own artistry.
In the opening speech of Henry V
for example the chorus
expresses his dissatisfaction
with the stage apparatus
of the globe theater.
The wooden O with small casques
and an unworthy scaffold,
all that is inadequate to the
epic greatness of Henry Campaign
in the vast fields of France.
Is Shakespeare here imagining
the as yet, unborn medium
of modern film with
its capacity to show
in wide screen splendor what
Shakespeare can only ask his
audience to imagine
in the mind's eye?
In other words, does filming
Shakespeare's plays allow us
to see qualities that
were there all along?
Shakespeare's cultural
after-life is also dependent
on our ability to change
the content of his work
to suit the tenor
and taste of the time
and the purposes of adaptors.
Practically no stage production
of Shakespeare performs
the text as written.
18th and 19th century dramatis
routinely produced their own
versions of the plays,
smoothing out the meter,
adding new characters
and subplots,
ruthlessly cutting what they
thought was obscure or body.
Even crafting happy
endings or the tragedies
as Name Tate famously did
for his 1681 King Lear,
the text of which ruled the
stage for the next 150 years.
Adaptors have filled in
the gaps in the lives
of Shakespeare's characters
and of Shakespeare himself
with fully fleshed out
fictional biographies,
prequels and sequels.
Some even inserting the
author into the mix.
The film Shakespeare in Love
for example continues
the long tradition
of imagining what we can't get
from the historical record.
The process by which
Shakespeare conceived
and wrote Romeo and Juliet.
Shakespeare's scripts are now
routinely recontextualized
in all manners of settings,
from the Tempest in Outer Space
to Macbeth in a mental hospital
to Midsummer Night's Dream
in modern Hollywood to Othello
in a southern prep school.
And film and television
have long dressed
up Shakespeare's work in
modern dress and language,
so that we're often
watching Shakespeare
without knowing we're doing so.
My students are often
surprised when I tell them
that 10 Things I Hate About You
is an adaptation of the Taming
of the Shrew, or the Zombie
romance Warm Bodies is a version
of Romeo and Juliet.
Indeed the increasingly
oral and visual nature
of 21st century Shakespeare,
that is to say it's
non-literary bent as well
as the globalization
of Shakespeare,
which is to say Shakespeare
in translation means
that our Shakespeare
is much less centered
on the specificities of
Shakespeare's language.
The wildly popular interactive
performance piece Sleep No More,
by the British Performance Troop
Punch Drunk uses Shakespeare's
Macbeth as its inspiration.
Not a word of Shakespeare's
script is ever uttered
as the audience wanders through
the company's meticulously
constructed environment and
watches the silent actors.
Lastly, Shakespeare's
availability
in the public realm becomes a
vehicle for cultural dialog.
A shear terrain on which
ideas can do battle or speak
across cultural divides.
With Shakespeare adaptors
speak to the present
through a well-established
common set of stories,
and they can also talk back to
the past or protest injustice
by co-opting Shakespeare's
inherited cultural authority.
The Tempest has long been
recognized as a founding text
in the discourse of
western colonialism.
A work that asserts the need to
subjugate unruly native people's
but through adaptation the
Tempest has become a powerful
mean to contest colonial
discourse,
to assert a perspective untold
in Shakespeare's original play.
In Aime Cesaire's
adaptation Une Tempete,
the rebellious Caliban proud
of his African heritage
eventually abandons the old
helpless prospero, gaining
in the process victory
over his colonial tormentor.
In Shylock is my Name,
one of the recent Hogarth
Shakespeare series,
a set of pros retellings
of Shakespeare's plays,
Howard Jacobson depicts
and erasable Shylock
who magically reappears
in contemporary Manchester
to a modern lapsed
Jew named Strolovich,
who is himself a
victim of anti-Semitism.
In the novel, Shylock
uses the situation
to answer Shakespeare's
anti-Semitic portrayal of him
in the Merchant of Venice.
He engineers a way to replay
the famous trial scene
on his own comic
terms, so that both he
and Strolovich are redeemed.
The contemporary Indian
filmmaker Vishal Bhardwaj,
has made a trio of films that
reimagined Indian culture,
I'm thinking of the films
Maqbool, Omkara and Haider.
He uses his Shakespeare
to comment on live issues
in Indian society, matters
like organized crime
and civic corruption, the
persistence of the caste system,
honor killing and terrorism.
The work of Bhardwaj
and other contemporary,
non-Anglophone adaptors suggest
that Shakespeare is becoming
a global Lingua Franca,
a set of plots, characters,
motifs and themes sufficiently
familiar worldwide to open
up new possibilities of
cross-cultural storytelling.
Let me end on two points,
first the relationship
between cultural
after-lives and adaptation
that I'm discussing is
not unique to Shakespeare.
He illustrates well the paradox
of art in the public realm.
That artworks robust cultural
after-life depends upon its
being taken up and manipulated
by later generations.
Not all of whom will be
faithful to the original
or respectful of its intentions.
Cultural after-lives depend
upon creative infidelity.
My second point is that if one
takes the long historical view
adaptation has long
been the cultural norm
in creative communities.
The notion that authors
can exercise control
of after their works have
entered the public arena is a
relatively new and
culturally specific notion,
modern copyright
dates from 1709.
And perhaps it's a historical
aberration challenged
by the creative impulse
to sample a new technology
that makes that especially
easy to do.
How to sustain current concepts
of copyright in the face
of contemporary adaptational
practice seems
to me a question worth asking.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Whitney Levandusky:
Thank you Doug.
So we know that the works of
Shakespeare were never protected
under US copyright law.
But, what if all
these adaptations
if they were protected
under copyright,
how long does protection last?
Duration of copyright
looks a lot different today
than it did in 1923.
For works created today, the
general rule is that duration
of copyright is life of
the author plus 70 years.
The works that expired on
January 1, 2019 protect -
were protected under
an original term
of 26 years and a renewal term.
The original term was secured
by publication with notice,
or registration with
the US Copyright Office.
The renewal term was
secured only by registration
with the Copyright Office.
This renewal term, it
was originally 26 years,
but through a series
of acts by Congress,
the last one being the Sonny
Bono Copyright Term Extension
Act, eventually the renewal
term was extended to 69 years.
This - Congresses ability
to pass these extensions was
affirmed by the Supreme Court
in Eldridge vs. Ashcroft.
As a result, these works
first publisher registered
in 1923 secured a
copyright term of 95 years.
This term structure,
an original term
and a renewal term
governs all works
that first secured protection
prior to January 1, 1978.
There are many technical
rules with duration
that I won't belabor today.
But know this, we
will see a new crop
of works enter the
public domain each year.
For example, works from 1924
will enter the public domain
in 2020.
1925, 2021 and so on.
The use of public domain images
and footage helps us - oops,
helps us to build
our sense of history.
They provide context to
first person narratives.
An artist can claim -
recast public domain works
to deepen our connections
to the past.
For example, Peter
Jackson's recent documentary,
They Shall Not Grow Old
modified original footage
from World War I
with colorization,
modern production techniques,
sound effects and voice acting.
In this clip courtesy of
the Imperial War Museum,
Jackson provides insight
into the thought process
behind their interpretation
of public domain footage.
>> Peter Jackson: Hi, I'm
Peter Jackson and I'm delighted
to present They Shall
Not Grow Old as part
of the Imperial Museum
Short Film Festival 2018.
[ Music ]
In the beginning we -
we were feeling our way
through what's going to be.
And by the time we were
finished, it really felt
like the natural thing to do.
Let them tell their story.
And they're not telling the
story of why the song happened
or what - why [Inaudible]
was such a disaster,
they're not telling that story.
They're just - they're
just telling us what it was
like to be a soldier.
And with that being
the sound track,
just purely voices it
then became apparent
that we should try to present
the images with as close
as we could to what
they experienced.
And they didn't see the war in
black and white for instance;
you know they saw
the war in color.
But we didn't want to
do reconstructions.
We could easily dress up
a lot of guys in uniforms
and filmed some stuff today,
but we didn't want to do that.
We wanted to use
strictly accurate footage.
Somehow the net result on
that is making these people
into human beings.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Whitney Levandusky: So to
provide a firsthand account
of how documentarians take
existing works as raw material
to create something
new, we are please
to have Nina Gilden Seavey
as a presenter today.
Seavey is an Emmy Award
Winning documentarian
with a 30 year history
in the non-fiction world.
Her films can be seen in
theaters, on television
and ancillary media and in
museums across the globe.
Seavey is a research
professor of history and media
and public affairs at George
Washington University.
And is the Director of the
Documentary Center in the School
of Media and Public Affairs.
She will share with us the
balance documentarian strike
when contending with
images and clips that may
or may not be publically
available.
She will also provide
insight into the industry
around public domain
materials and it's bearing
on creating historical
documentaries.
So, please join me in
welcoming Nina to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Nina Gilden Seavey:
Thank you.
Well I'm not as famous
as Peter Jackson,
but he and I share
the same problems
of how do you create
something out of the past?
Now in his World War I film
he used public domain images
as archival material.
I mean it was literally
artifact of a certain era,
about which he was making
a very literal film.
Most documentary filmmakers
are not doing that.
We're taking images that we
need to represent a story
that we are shaping into an
entirely different narrative.
So we're not using these
images as artifact,
but we're using them
as representation.
So I - because I am
a professor I'm going
to give you a little assignment.
I am going to show
you a clip from a film
that I made a trailer from
my film A Paralyzing Fear
of the Story of Polio
in America.
And this film posed a number
of interesting challenges
about the public domain.
Because of course,
filmmakers are omnivorous.
We need not one series
of images,
we need thousands of images.
While I was sitting here,
I was actually thinking
like how many - like what would
be the average number of images
in the 90 minute film, which
is what A Paralyzing Fear was.
So I thought well an image
on the screen changes
about once every
five seconds, right?
So theoretically you could
have somewhere between 900
and 1,000 images that need
to be somehow collected
and in any given film, and you
need to either own the right
to that material, or it has
to be in the public domain,
which means it's not - it's
free and you can use it at will.
Well the problem for
documentary filmmakers is
that we are not just
an omnivorous group,
but we're an impoverished group.
And so this issue
of what do we use
and how do we use it becomes
kind of an interesting,
I wouldn't say it's
a game that we play,
but it is a little bit of one.
And there has become, because of
the kind of voracious appetite
that documentary filmmakers
have we have become a bit
of an industry for the both
materials that are in copyright
and that which is entered
into the public domain.
Now, the good news for
documentary filmmakers is
that we don't have to wait
very long because for you know,
unlike Shakespeare where
we had to wait for many,
many years for that to
enter the public domain,
in documentary much
of what has come
into the public domain
were works created
by the Federal Government
themselves, which is interesting
because the Federal Government
is indeed a very large producer
of filmed work.
So there is an unending
repository
that I send my students out
into College Park Maryland
and they have to go look,
like on a treasure hunt
for some of these images.
Because they are fertile
territory for great stories
and the kinds of material
that we love to use in films,
because A, there's a lot of it.
And B, it's free.
So, hence my assignment to
you, which is to take a look
at this clip and I'm going
to talk to you a little bit
about the problems and the
opportunities of public domain
as related to this
particular film.
It's a little five minute clip.
I kind of pulled a little bit
of a fast one on our AV people,
so the people who are
livestreaming this may not be
able to get it because I'm going
to show another film a
little bit later along
that is definitely not
in the public domain.
But this one is the trailer
for A Paralyzing Fear,
the Story of Polio in America,
which is also on YouTube.
So, follow me along and
take a look at this clip
and then we're going to
talk about the conundrum
of public domain in documentary.
[ Music ]
[ Film ]
Okay thank you.
So here was the problem.
When I decided to make this
film, the - I went to the March
of Dimes and I said, "I want
to make a film about Polio."
And they said, "Well you an
everybody else who has ever come
to us, and the answer is no."
Because they owned all of the
rights to all of the material.
So not being one to ever take
no for an answer, I begged
and I pleaded and I collected
all of the best historians
of science and medicine and many
famous people who had had Polio
and they lobbied on my behalf.
And finally the March of
Dimes said, "Okay we're going
to let you be the
first filmmaker
that we have ever
given our archive to.
There is a warehouse
in Fort Lee, New Jersey
and we don't know how
many films are there,
and how many photographs.
But we're going to
give you the key."
So I got my trusted
crew together
and got an 18 wheeler
truck and we went
up to Fort Lee, New Jersey.
And sure enough we
pulled out 3,000 films
and 5,000 photographs.
It's an interesting
amount of material.
So, I started looking at
this stuff and I thought
to myself, well wait a minute.
The Federal Government
was involved in the fight
against Polio, so a lot
of this is their footage.
And as we find out in this piece
and as you probably
know already,
the person who really
led the fight
against Polio was
FDR, as President.
And so a lot of that material
was also taken during the time
that he was President
of the United States.
And was in the FDR
Library at Warm Springs.
And so honestly I started to
question a little bit the March
of Dimes claim on this material.
Now, we came to what we
call a blanket license.
I paid them a heap of money,
they give me a heap of film
and photographs,
everybody goes home happy.
But, in the question of what
was in the public domain,
it really became kind of a bit
of a head scratcher for me.
Because I thought wait a minute,
they are claiming copyright
to something that I know
for a fact they don't own.
But I decided we're going
to leave that to the side
for the moment because
some of the material,
I mean they were a private
foundation with monies raised
through private funds.
And so a lot of it was theirs.
But it was all mixed together.
And hence, the problem
for the documentarian.
Is that there is - we live
in the era of motion picture
and have since the
beginning of the 20th century.
And where this material
comes from
and how do you trace it back
becomes a bit of a puzzle.
Well that puzzle becomes I
think ever more interesting
because somewhere,
somewhere along the line,
especially after the cable
industry entered sort
of the documentary filmmaking
world with the History Channel
and Discovery Channel and
National Geographic Channel,
and all of these other channels.
And the need for documentary
films just exploded,
so did the need for material
around which these
films would be made.
So, many enterprising
young entrepreneurs came
to Washington, to the Library
of Congress where we are today
and to the National Archives
where we are down the street,
and they copied everything,
which is interesting, right?
Because what they did is
they took everything that was
in the public domain, and you
have all of these filmmakers
from all around the
world who was omnivorous
and finance starved as I am
and they sell the material
that is in the public domain.
They don't call it
a right's fee,
they call it you know
an acquisition fee
or an administrative fee.
But in fact, what you're doing
is you're paying for the rights
to public domain material
because you're sitting
out in Omaha, Nebraska
and Nebraska Public
Television wants you
to make a nice documentary
about you know,
an issue for which
there is plenty
of public domain material.
It's going to cost a
lot of money to send you
to the National Archive, plus
you probably don't have the time
that it takes, which
his six weeks
to get the material we produced.
So, there is an industry
that has actually developed
around public domain
material because we are
as I said a voracious
consumer of material.
So - but there is still
a lot of question.
Just in that little clip
alone there are I don't know,
over 100 images, right?
From the past and I can promise
you that the March of Dimes,
nor any other rights holder
knows who owns what to whom.
We do know that probably the -
you know the Walt
Disney Material,
we know who owns that, right?
But aside from that I can
promise you nobody else is quite
clear on the - on that subject.
So, it's an interesting
problem of how do you tether out
and documentary filmmakers,
I'm not going to bore you
with the legalities of this.
I mean lawyers kind of
owing - owning our lives.
We all documentary
filmmakers carry errors
and admissions insurance.
And that guarantees
to a broadcaster
that when we bring something
to them, that they're not going
to libel for violation
of copyright,
but rather we take
the responsibility.
We take the liability for any
error that we may have incurred
so that nobody is
held responsible
at the network level, but the
documentary filmmaker is going
to take all the responsibility
on him or herself,
which is quite a burden.
But the fact is is
that trying to parse
out where does this stuff come
from, who owns it and when it is
in the public domain why
am I really paying for it?
Because it has become a very
large profitable industry
for many companies, and I
salute them for their you know,
their enterprise that
have managed to take kind
of the cabilzation of
American life and turned it
into quite a profitable
business for them.
The last little bit I'm going
to talk about is the confusion
between - amongst documentary
filmmakers and the public
at large about what is in public
domain and what is fair use.
Fair use, and my students
do this all the time.
"Oh I can use that,
its fair use.
It's on YouTube."
Uh oh -
There is a common belief
that if it's out there,
and I can get it, it's mine.
And fair use and
I'm not going to go
into you know the
complications of it,
is actually a fairly
limited classification
under which a documentary
filmmaker
or someone else can
take a piece of material
that is indeed copyrighted and
used for their own purposes.
One of those - the central
premise of fair use is
that the rights holder, if
you're creating a polemic
of something and they would have
every reason not to grant you -
not to grant you copyright
in this issue of the polemic
and it's kind of part of -
in the public discourse then
that is a pretty
legitimate fair use claim.
I'm going to show you a clip
from my most recent work
and this cannot be streamed
because the question
of fair use has yet to
be fought on this one.
But it does pose sort of
an interesting challenge
to who owns what and how much
documentary filmmakers sort
of claim for themselves.
Anyway, this is a clip from my
new project called My Fugitive.
And will not be streamed.
What I found, and I'm not
going to tell you everything.
The project will
drop on May 4, 2020,
which is the 50th anniversary
of the Kent State Murders,
was the connection between what
happened to Howard Becanick
and his other co-defendants.
And the investigation
into the conspiracy
to assassinate Dr.
Martin Luther King.
So, the question as to what is
going to enter into fair use
on this particular
project is going to be kind
of a long and protractive one.
I have great legal
representation.
So - but it is an
interesting kind of conundrum -
for documentary filmmakers
between what is
in the public domain and what
is available to us for fair use,
which is an altogether other
and interesting dialog.
On that note, I'd like to
conclude, and I thank you
for your time and
appreciate your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Whitney Levandusky:
Thank you Nina.
So one of the things that Nina
touched on was the essential
and sometimes difficult
issue of access,
that idea of sending
students out to College Park
to do the treasure hunt
for government works.
Access to public domain
works is as important
to the public domain as
the public domain itself.
You can find and use public
domain works at a number
of cultural institutions
from your local library
to a national museum.
Here at the copyright
office we have much
of our records available
to the public.
Our production as
government workers,
and we are expanding the
number and type of records
that we can make
public available online.
The Library of Congress has
many of its collections scant
and available for use.
In the films that we're
sharing today come
from the Packard Campus of
the Library of Congress.
The Packard Campus has a
screening room and theater
in Culpepper, Virginia.
In addition, there
are many private
and non-profit online resources
for public domain works,
including Project
Gutenberg, HathiTrust,
Amazon, Kindle and Google.
So, onto musicals.
A quintessentially
American art form.
From the late 19th century to
today musicals have evolved
in form, narrative
and production.
This year, musical works
from multiple productions
enter the public domain,
including the Rise of Rose
O'Reilly by George M. Cohan,
A Perfect Lady by George
Gershwin, Music Box Revue
by Irving Berlin and the
Wallflower by Oscar Hammerstein.
Our next presenter
is Benjamin West.
A director, producer, performer,
writer and musical
theater historian.
His current projects
include the Showtime Trilogy,
Direct from Proctors
23rd Street Theater
for one night only,
January 16, 1920.
And 514 Broadway.
West's directing credits
include Unsung Caroline Lee
for Lincoln Center's American
Songbook, Gatsby the Songs
and Concert, Make Mine Manhattan
and the Fig Leaves are Falling.
His Broadway credits include
assistant director and drama
for Old Acquaintance, assistant
producer for August Osage County
and the Homecoming, and product
assistant for Talk Radio.
He is the founder of
Unsung Musical Company,
a 2017 recipient of Lincoln
Center's Martin E. Segal Award.
He will share with us
a case study in the use
of public domain works from his
documentary musical series The
Showtime Trilogy.
The second installment of this
trilogy entitled 45 Minutes
from Coon Town, a Celebration
of Black Musical Theater,
tracing its history
from the late 1800's
through 1999 will
open on September 12,
2019 at the York Theater
Company in New York City.
So, without further
ado Benjamin West.
[ Applause ]
>> Benjamin West: Good morning.
Thank you Whitney.
I am Ben West, and I am
a musical theater artist
and historian.
My focus and my passion
is really two fold.
One illuminating the
intersection of past, present
and future, effectively
how successive generations
of artists and audiences
continue to influence
and inform one another, and
two exploring how the American
musical is a reflection
of American consciousness.
So effectively it's
capturing our social, cultural
and political sensibilities
at any moment
in time throughout its history.
There are two quotes that
speak to both of these themes
and I happen to love,
one is by a lyricist
and composer Harold Rome,
who was a tremendous
Broadway review writer,
and also wrote a number of book
musicals, Destry Rides Again
and Fanny are two of his shows.
And he says whether you want to
be original, or whether you want
to be conventional you still
have to know what has been done
in order to be either.
This is a quote that
I particularly love.
And the other one is from
YipHarburg who you'll know
as the lyricist of
the Wizard of Oz,
of Brother Can you Spare a Dime
and a number of Broadway
musicals.
And he says, "A songwriter
is really a journalist
of time with music."
So both of these
quotes certainly feed me
and I think feed my focus.
And with these two focuses
I'm looking a lot at writers,
creators, craftsman of the form
and my projects tend to deal
with the history of
the American musical
in some way, shape or form.
And in dealing with the history
of the American musical
I am working a lot
with public domain materials.
And in fact all five of
these songs that you see
up here are currently in
public domain, and all five
of these songs are
also incorporated
into my current project,
which is the Showtime Trilogy.
And with that, I'll give you a
brief background on the trilogy
and then we're going to look
at two specific sequences
so we can have a sense of how
public domain works are used
in the creation of
this new work.
The Showtime Trilogy is a
project I began developing
about five years ago now, almost
five years ago and research
for the piece has taken me to
more than 20 different archives
across the country,
including here in DC,
the Library of Congress of
course, the copyright office
and actually also Howard
University, I should mention.
The trilogy is three documentary
musicals which celebrate
and chart the history
of the American musical.
Now the project aims to be
comprehensive in its coverage,
so we go back to minstrelsy
and vaudeville in the 1800's.
We move through the turn of
the century musical burlesque
and American operetta,
George M. Cohan and so forth,
all the way to the
works of George C. Wolfe
and Jason Robert Brown in the
1990's and the cut off point
for the project is 1999.
In terms of the documentary
musical construct.
It is a form that
I've been developing
over the past several years,
and I do believe it's
unique in its form.
We are essentially weaving
live music and live performance
through this non-fiction
historical narrative
to tell the story of
the American musical.
Now each piece is
designed as a solo show.
And the narrator is very
much an omniscient vessel,
through whom the
history flows forth,
and in whom the various
styles of music
and performance are embodied.
Each piece, I should also
mention is fully scripted
and so it is a fully
scripted musical.
Again, it's non-fiction,
so we're not talking
about a historical or
biographic dramatization,
but it's actually
documentary in nature.
And as such, we're
utilizing narration, quotes,
newspaper articles and existing
songs to tell this story
of a uniquely American art form.
And it's very much; I should
point out an active story.
It's a very active,
theatrical story.
And in terms of the songs the
trilogy all told uses more
than 100 songs in the telling of
this story, 100 existing songs.
And that's 100 -
more than 100 songs
over all three installments.
So, I'll break down quickly
the installments for you.
The first installment and
primary entry is Showtime,
the First 100 years of
the American Musical.
And this really looks at the
evolution of the form itself
and its cultural impact.
And just a quick
example of what I mean
by the evolution of the form.
New York Time article 1907 this
is - it reads in part talking
about the form about the
musical, this American musical.
New York Times 1907,
"Fashions in plays may change,
but musical comedy remains about
the same from beginning to end.
It is taken as a
matter of course
that the tunes will
be reminiscent.
The characters are nearly always
the same and the comedy in many
of these shows is
the saddest feature.
There are, as a rule, only
two classes of musical comedy.
The good and the bad."
And then we jump forward 40
years and Alan J. Lerner,
who you'll know as the
author of My Fair Lady
and Brigadoon speaking about the
American musical, again 1947.
And he says, "The
musical theater
in America is becoming a vital
medium of dramatic expression.
With words, music and
movement, blended together
in complete synchronization
a real art form is revealed."
So Showtime is essentially
looking at this evolution
from minstrelsy, vaudeville,
early musical comedy
into the real art form being
revealed and through to the 90s.
I'll also point out this first
installment premiered this past
September at the
Theater at St. Peter's.
And the second installment
45 Minutes
from Coon Town will premier
this coming September
at the same venue.
45 Minutes from Coon
Town is specifically
about Black musicals and
Black writers in particular.
And the third and final
installment is 68 Ways to Go,
which is about female
musical theater, writers
and that will premier in 2020.
And then the plan is to premier
the trilogy in its entirety
in 2021 where we will have
each show in succession.
Now that's the trilogy and we'll
take a look at two sequences
from the primary entry Show
time the First 100 years
to give a sense of how public
domain material has been used
in creating the narrative
and creating the peace.
Showtime the First 100 years,
the primary entry utilizes
59 existing songs in total,
21 of those are public domain
and 38 are still
under copyright.
The show is two acts, including
the intermission it runs
about 2:20, 2:25.
We'll look at two
specific songs that are
in Showtime the first 100 Years.
They are Jazz Baby
and Prohibition Blues.
Completely coincidentally
both are from 1919
and both are co-authored
by a female writer.
Jazz Baby has lyrics
by Blanche Merrill
and Prohibition Blues
has music by Nora Bayes.
Now when we encounter these
songs in Showtime it's
in a scene that deals with
the early 20th century.
We begin the scene talking
about the various musical styles
that are spreading across
the stage at that time.
And then we get to rag time
and its evolution into jazz.
And you'll see we come
to Jazz Baby here.
So, just a brief
point about part
of the language of the show.
The lyric in almost all of the
songs was specifically chosen
to filter into the narrative,
to become part of the narrative.
So we mention rag time evolving,
but we don't actually
mention jazz.
And so the question of into
what does it evolve is answered
through the song.
So music comes in and we have
the first chorus of jazz baby
and then you'll see music
under at the bottom of that.
Again another part of the
language in storytelling
in this particular show, music
is woven through the narrative
through much of the show.
So you'll see music
will continue
under for an Irving
Berlin quote.
And again speaking
further to the language
of the show you'll
see a parenthetical
that says down beats only.
Then we have one line of dialog
and then we have music
full for the quote.
Music and also acoustic
sounds effects that are made
by the drummer and his various
toys are used throughout the
show, throughout
the entire piece
as really connective tissue, and
also as oral quotation marks.
So, when you see - we're going
to show a video clip of this,
you'll see that there's going
to be just downbeats only
for two bars where we set up the
quote, and then music will come
in fully under the quote itself.
So, it's to help
differentiate and delineate
between what is narration
and what is the actual quote.
Following the Irving Berlin
quote we go into another bit
of Jazz Baby and then you'll
see music under - at the bottom
of the screen here, stop time.
So we're going to go
music under again,
this time for a Rosamond
Johnson quote.
He was an early Black composer.
And this is going to be
speaking about Negro spirituals
and the routes of this form
and essentially harking back
to slavery - harkening
back to slavery.
And in so doing the feel of the
underscore is entirely different
than the feel of the more
celebratory Irving Berlin quote.
We're going to be in stop time,
which you'll see in a moment.
And also you'll notice
that it's going to go minor
in what we're talking about.
And music will cut out after
that, so I'll stop there,
and then we're going to take
a look at the video right now.
I want to mention just
three quick points.
My music collaborator
for the entire trilogy,
all three installments
is Fran Menaric
who has created all new
arrangements for all
of the songs, and
helped me to weave them
through the narrative
quite literally.
Our director and musical stager
for Showtime the First 100
years is Shannon Lewis.
And then at the beginning of
the clip there is a drum roll,
that's not actually
part of the script.
That is just setting
up the clip;
so disregard the drum roll.
All right, so let's take a look
at this Jazz Baby sequence.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
So that is a bit of
the Jazz Baby sequence.
And in fact, it continues
right on.
There's no break from the
Rosamond Johnson quote,
we go into a socio
political section,
small sociopolitical section.
Because again, one of the themes
being the American musical
as a reflection of our
social consciousness.
So again from Rosamond
Johnson we go directly
into a section about
Black writers.
And so I actually have a
question for everyone here.
I wonder if anyone can name any
Black musical theater writers
working early 20th
century, 1900 to 1930?
Any guesses?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes.
Yes, Colin Johnson for sure.
Yes, awesome.
Great. So there were actually
quite a few Black writers
working on Broadway in
the early 20th century,
relatively speaking.
Certainly the form was still
dominated by White men.
But there were a tremendous
number of Black artists.
I'll point out Bob
Cole who you mentioned,
who I consider the father
of Black musical theater.
He is - he devised what is
considered the first full length
legitimate Black musical
comedy, A Trip to Coon Town.
This was in 1897 and that is
the Coon Town that we reference
in our 45 Minutes
from Coon Town title.
And I'll also mention at the
top there, James P. Johnson
and then toward the
middle Cecil Mack
because they wrote
the Charleston,
which you heard earlier.
And that was from
1923, which you pointed
out from a Black musical
called Running Wild.
And then from the Black
author section we jump right
into female writers
and so again I wonder,
can anyone name any female
musical theater writers working
early 20th century,
1900's to 1930?
Any guesses?
There were also quite a
number of women working.
Dorothy Fields, I
think you probably -
if you don't know the name,
you probably know her work.
I can't give you anything but
Love Baby, on the Sunny Side
of the Street, a
number of pop standards.
I want to also call attention
to Alma Sanders who is
at the bottom right
of the screen.
Because her, a bit
of her story speaks
to how essentially the social
dynamics are informing the
American musical.
She eventually moved to New
York, but was actually living
in Detroit when she
began her career.
She would eventually
marry her lyricist,
her lyric writing partner.
He would be her second husband.
She was married to her first
husband at the time though
in Detroit, who wanted to
get a divorce from her.
And she was on the
cusp of breaking
through in the musical theater.
She would go on to write a
handful of shows in the 20's
and in 1921 is when
the divorce happened.
So I'll read, this is from the
Detroit Free Press March 1921.
"Ernest E. Benjamin was
granted a divorce from his wife,
the well-known song
writer Alma Sanders.
Benjamin testified
that his wife's success
in writing two song
hits turned her head.
And she refused to
keep house any longer.
[ Laughter ]
Or, to live in Detroit.
He said she spent much of
her time in New York coming
and going as she pleased."
So that's just a fun little bit.
I'm in the midst of writing
the women's show right now,
we start readings next week.
So I enjoy her story.
And so then, from female
writers we cap this jazz
and sociopolitical sequence
with prohibition blues
and we get there - again
we're early 20th century;
so that's women's right to
vote being ratified in 1920,
also income tax and prohibition.
So again, prohibition
blues brings us back
to the jazz vernacular.
We'll play the prohibition
blues clip now and then I'll pop
up the script page for
it immediately after.
So, this is prohibition blues.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
And I just want to
mention again, the music is
by Nora Bayes who is one
of the first female
musical theater composers,
who I happen to love.
She was a very big
vaudeville and stage star.
And so here's just a quick
look at the script page
for prohibition blues.
Again you'll see we cap the idea
of social consciousness
at the top.
We go into prohibition blues,
again part of the language,
the music will continue under
for a final quote about jazz
to wrap up and come full
circle with this jazz sequence
and then we move forward.
Just in terms of using
the songs in the narrative
and in telling the story these
two songs were used almost
in their entirety, but
that's not the case
with all of the songs.
In some cases we use
just two or three lines,
in some cases we just use a
chorus; so it really depends
on the needs of the
specific moment
and how the song is utilized
in the story telling.
And with that I think
I have completed.
So that is how essentially the
songs are used in the show.
And thank you for your time.
[ Applause ]
>> Whitney Levandusky:
Thank you so much Ben.
Before we go, there
is a fourth speaker
that we were hoping
to have here today.
I want to take a moment to
highlight a powerful example
of how the use of public
domain works can help us better
understand ourselves
and our current time.
Nina's presentation highlighted
for us the way documentarians
use the public domain
to bring truth and
understanding to often difficult
and painful experiences.
We were hoping to
have Taina Caragol,
Curator at the Smithsonian
National Portrait Gallery join
us today to discuss
the works included
in the recent exhibition,
Unseen our past in a new light,
to highlight a similar
practice among visual artists.
Unfortunately because of
the government shutdown,
she is unable to participate
in the event today.
Caragol co-curated with
Osman Naim the works
of Ken Gonzalez Day and Titus
Kafar to product an exhibition
that considers the intersections
between portraiture,
nation building and
museum practice.
A brief warning before we begin,
the images that follow directly
content with America's history
of slavery and lynching.
Gonzalez Day photographs
historical objects,
be they from archives or museums
and suggests new meanings
for them by thoughtfully
altering their composition
or display.
Here we have two works from
his erased lynching series.
This series Gonzalez Day tells
us was sparked in response
to anti-immigration rhetoric
that directly led to an increase
in vigilante activity
along the US/Mexican border
in the early 2000's.
Each image is a recasting
of lynching photograph
that took place in the United
States between 1850 and 1942.
Where Gonzalez Day rephotographs
the image and removes the victim
and the hanging materials
from the composition.
Gonzalez Day has researched and
uncovered 350 cases of lynching
in the state of California
alone as detailed in his book,
Lynching in the West,
1850 to 1935.
As Caragol states, in
unseen's catalog rather
than inflicting more
violence upon the victims,
Gonzalez Day directs our
attention to perpetrators
and bystanders to consider
mob violence nationwide,
exposing the vulnerability of
African Americans, Latinos,
Native Americans, Jews
and immigrant communities.
Their absent bodies stand
for their untold histories
against the myth of a White
Anglo American identity.
Titus Kafar paints
in the tradition
of Euro American
Colonial portraiture,
but then adds a contemporary
layer that is often physical,
such as cutting, shrouding
or smearing the canvas.
Before us we have a
well-known portrait
of Thomas Jefferson shrouding
or revealing the portrait
of an enslaved Black woman.
In Kafar's words, "This
portrait is at once
about Sally Mae Hemmings
and Thomas Jefferson,
as well as the many woman who's
liberty was taken from them.
And whose tragic
relationships have been shrouded
by historically inaccurate
narratives of deified men
in positions of power."
The process of hiding the known
and revealing the unknown,
according to co-curator
Osma Naim makes us realize
that history is complex.
It's messy.
And filled with many
different perspectives,
and that ultimately
our understanding
of the past is more
complete when more
of our stories can be told.
Both Gonzalez Day and Kafar
use public domain works
to probe foundational myths
in order to reclaim a space
for those left unseen.
I would encourage you to seek
out both their works not only
as an illustration of the power
of using the public domain,
but also to challenge
how each of us sees
and understands our place
in the United States.
Now, we are essentially
out of time for today.
But I would like to invite
anyone who wishes to stay
after for an informer Q&A with
our presenters and thank you.
We will have Katie
Rowland bring us home.
[ Applause ]
>> Katie Rowland: Thank
you everyone and thank you
for joining our celebration
of the Lifecycle of Copyright.
As Whitney said we're going
to conclude our program now,
thanking all of our panelists.
If anyone would like to welcome
- join me in thanking them
for their participation -
[ Applause ]
Thank you all and we're so happy
you could enjoy our celebration
of the life cycle of
copyright with us.
Until our next event
on April 25,
which is about the world IP
day, about going for the gold
in sports, we'll see you then.
Thank you.